we just mentioned of course 2020
presidential candidate former
congresswoman tulsi gabbard
tulsi um
first there seems to be this
palpable concern not just among the dams
but all their media boosters
about
biden and harris so they're leapfrogging
kind of both to go right to
wonderboy what do you think about this
yeah laura well first of all you know
this washington post article is just
another example of how the mainstream
media is essentially the propaganda arm
of the democratic party elite
um you know it it doesn't really matter
kind of how they're ranking these people
because ultimately we know that they'll
never nominate anybody or promote
anybody who
you know believes in and supports the
constitutional bill of rights they'll
never nominate anybody who doesn't toe
the line with their woke cancel culture
pushing their policies things like
taking away parents rights uh you know
making sure that they have open borders
and and canceling our free speech as
americans they'll never nominate anybody
who doesn't bow to the interest of the
military-industrial complex and so you
know you mentioned we're 15 months into
this administration we're going to keep
seeing more articles like this from the
mainstream media as they push different
candidates or promote people that they
like and we've just got to know every
time we see this
this is propaganda coming from the
democratic party elite
i think people are just
discounting all of this at this point
and that's why to hear them
in the media so upset
over the last few days about the
republicans finally pulling out of these
obscene debates was just laughable you
you got completely hosed in the debates
as i recall yeah and i think you said
something at the time on stage like
hello i'm here
uh
what's your reaction to the decision by
the rnc to say uh no thanks
yeah i don't blame them you know as as
you said having been on that stage and
hearing you know kind of the the
rhetoric coming from the organizers and
and the mainstream media news channels
they partner with like oh this is going
to be fair this is unbiased all the
candidates will get an equal shot like
that's bs laura i think on average on
every debate that i participated in
usually they went two hours maybe i got
seven total minutes of talk time on
there and so you know it to to say that
this is an unbiased you know service to
the american people upholding our
democracy it's all it's nonsense really
what it is is political theater that's
being organized by the propaganda arm of
this you know permanent washington
establishment the the democratic party
elite uh and so you know good for the
republican party for uh walking away by
the way looking at the things republican
party was asking for very reasonable
requests very reasonable requests and
the fact that they rejected them kind of
shows their hand about their bias
now tulsi they're just fanatics what are
your what's your reaction to chris coons
actually floating the idea of american
troops on the ground in ukraine tulsi
what are your thoughts on that
it is incredibly dangerous for uh us
senator to to push this idea
um you know
there are so many issues with this
number one congress has not debated the
american people have not
had their chance to say that this is
what they want or they don't want so
they're defying the constitution even
putting this forward
number two how does it serve our
interests as the united states how does
it serve our national security it does
not it will undermine it uh i think of
my brothers and sisters in uniform who
would be the ones whose lives that are
put on the line in what would
essentially kick off world war iii and a
direct challenge to nuclear-armed
russia
risking nuclear war that's exactly what
he's proposing and everyone should be
very clear-eyed as they hear this kind
of rhetoric coming from washington
a lot of people thinking it's the drip
drip drip tulsi great to see you thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else